[Music]  there's a lot of Olympic spirit right  out there in the country in America  right now and well someone on our staff  though isn't as excited he thinks that  some people may have gone a little  overboard in their enthusiasm about the  Olympics here to explain is one of our  writers mr. Deon Cole thanks Conan  I am glad everyone's enjoying the  Olympics but I noticed something  yesterday that bothered me yesterday on  the Google search site it was dedicated  at home screen to the Olympic runners  and they had a cartoon of an image of a  black guy running take a look no big  deal to you alright well to me it looked  like a black man running on watermelon  but if that wasn't enough look at what  Google put on their site today chicken  real always I can't wait to see what  they come up with tomorrow  [Applause]